hey youtubers it's Charlie and during my
walking dead episode 12 review i asked
you guys to all submit your questions so
i picked inner them to answer in this
video with one bonus question we also
owe a giant high-five to the winner of
my week for giveaway congratulations to
Brendan Martin you win a twenty-dollar
amazon gift card i'll be contacting you
on your channel for details but if
you're finding me for the first time
just as a way for me to say thank you to
you guys for being so awesome i give
away a twenty dollar gift card in each
of my review videos so let's answer some
questions number one Rachel King asks
how come the people in the clubhouse
didn't turn into zombies so they had a
class war between the rich people and
the poor people so the ones that died
and didn't turn into walkers to just
been shot or stabbed in the head so they
wouldn't have turned question number two
Camille parmer asks given the DC spoon
bet found at the Country Club do you
think that Beth Daryl and Maggie's group
will be the ones to make it to DC or do
you think one of them will be found by
the hunters I think they'll be the ones
to head to DC based on the teaser for
the next episode it seems like Maggie's
group will run into trouble I don't know
that it's the hunters careful for comic
book spoilers real quick though it was
originally Rick's group that ran into
them on the way to Washington DC they
could just be changing things in giving
that plot line to the groups from this
episode or the hunters could have been
that group that Rick ran into last week
it really does seem like Rick's group on
the show is headed to sanctuary so I
think it's safe to assume that Beth and
Maggie Scroope will be the one to run
into hunters on the way to Alexandria
question number three the mangas asks
what are the possibilities of a Beth
Carl hook up down the road so unless
Carl's group meets up with their group 0
if they do meet up before the end of the
season I'd also say 0 if Carl does end
up hooking up with someone eventually
it'll probably some characters they meet
in sanctuary or some other future
location but I don't see any Carl
hookups in the near future though
question number 4 trade d 1515 asks will
bethe and darryl make it to the
sanctuary i don't think they're going to
meet up with Rick's group I do think
that they'll make contact before the end
of the season the show is really making
it seem like half the people are headed
to sanctuary and the other half are
headed Alexandria so I hope that answers
your question I just think one group is
going one way and the other is going the
other way question number 5 z Jordan Z
LFC asks
do you think the Beth will die soon I
would be so bummed but it is a
possibility I know that someone will die
right now Bob Stokey Maggie and Beth are
highest on my list I did agree with
Beth's comment though that Darrell will
probably the last one alive question
number 6 eng women 143 asks same the new
promo do you think that all of Maggie's
group will make it or will we lose
someone or all of them I definitely
think that they want us to think that
someone's going to die it seems like the
worst thing they run into next week
though is a group of walkers that falls
on them so if someone does die it could
be that they just die in the future from
an infected Walker by it question number
7 min truck owes 360 ests in the teaser
you can see Sasha screamed for a
millisecond Bob who also appears like
he's killing something in the floor do
you think that he's killing himself or
getting killed by a walker or killing
someone else I really hoped in its Bob
that's getting killed because I like all
the other girls you know Maggie Sasha
and Beth I do have a sneaking suspicion
that one of the women is going to die
this season though so I am getting a
little bit worried for Beth and Maggie
because Maggie was actually one of my
predictions earlier in the year question
number 8 John Redgrave asks what were
you most afraid of in this episode and
did it give you any jump scares there
wasn't anything that made me jump but i
did get really claustrophobic when they
were inside that trunk i do also squirm
just a little bit whenever walkers
almost by people like when Beth was in
the country club fending off that one
walker with one hand question number 9
chaos team asks what do you think
started the apocalypse I think it was
probably a mutated super virus because
the conceit is that everyone just lives
with it and they only turned if they die
I think that it's spread before anyone
realized what it was and it was probably
something that mutated out of a
pharmaceutical company test like they
were trying to make a vaccine for
something else and things just went
horribly horribly wrong so I don't think
that it was someone evil trying to
infect the entire world question number
10 infamous adam asks i'm starting to
notice that the TV show is catching up
with the comic so I was wondering what
would the show do once it catches up
with the comic so Robert Kirkman sits in
the writers room every day and writes
stories with them so he would ply just
come up with new ideas he probably has a
hundred different ideas for where the
show could go if it ever goes beyond the
comic the spin-off show that they're
doing will only be stuff that's not on
the comic so if he can do that that it
would be pretty easy to create new
original stories for these characters
right now and one last bonus question
the non-key asks do you think that Daryl
rather Norman Reedus really ate snake in
that scene so Norman Reedus actually
revealed that that was a real snake
which was pretty cool or pretty gross
depending on how you look at it so thank
you so much for submitting your
questions guys this is a lot of fun
again high fives to Brendan Martin for
winning this week's giveaway the next
round will start whenever I post my
episode 13 review I might also be doing
a predictions video later this week if i
have time i'm also doing Game of Thrones
and stick of truth tonight so i'll try
and post game of thrones super late and
then stick a truth in the morning it'll
be a let's play video but i'm really
excited it's gonna be a lot of fun right
now click here for my review the episode
and click here for that game of Thrones
video thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight don't forget
South Park videos coming it's gonna be a
lot of fun high fives